good morning millennials and juicy
scoopers today is such an exciting day
because we're having i haven't decided
if i want to call it the morning scoop
or the juicy toast i think they both
work but i am joined by one of my idols
queen of podcasting heather mcdonald
hello heather how are you
i'm so good thank you so much everyone's
really excited about us doing this
together and
i love your show as well and there's so
many things that i i know we're gonna
get into and
share probably some very similar uh
thoughts
well like you are my favorite person
ever i think you are so funny i was just
watching this tick tock of you calling a
restaurant pretending to be your
assistant um and i cannot lie like i've
definitely done that um and you went
viral on tick tock so at first i just
want to congratulate you because it's so
hard
thank you you know i i try and you never
know
what
what gets the action i cannot figure it
out we've tried to figure out when you
post what you do if you use that voice
that's like i tried dancing with my
grandma like i don't know what works
what doesn't
how something can get like seven million
views and another one like fifteen
thousand you're like i can't figure it
out but uh you know it's fun it's always
the one that you work so hard on and
spend hours on that gets no views and
then this like piece of [ __ ] you throw
up goes crazy vile where you look
heinous you have a double chin that
always happens to me right
before i dive in i love it i need to ask
how you are doing because you made waves
like major waves you i thought first of
all i want to ask you if you're okay and
then i want to just talk about like how
you handled the situation from like a
social media perspective because you
nailed it like i cannot believe you
posted the video of you fainting i can't
lie i watched it 100 times i want to
know how you are doing you fractured
your skull you fainted for those who
don't know you fainted on stage in the
middle of a stand-up set which is like i
think every comic's worst nightmare so
how are you doing it's actually very
much it was very much in the beginning
like right so it was like within like
the first like three minutes
and of the of the saturday show so i
done fried find the friday night before
and first of all no i'm completely fine
um
i was what i was recovering from was
just the crack of my skull which there
was no outside bleed you know it was
like internal bleeding inside a crack of
a skull and then they by the next within
24 hours or like it's already healing
but they said you'll have some um
residual effects like you know and and
that happened but now we're out to be
like laying down doing pilates and i
come up and i'm like dizzy but that now
is all gone so i'm like 100 percent but
okay good um i just was so
horrified and all i could think about
was
the people that got a sitter was
planning on this
and that they saw me do this and so when
i just went back last weekend and the um
the manager of the club goes i don't
know if you remember but you were like
okay let me just get a glass of water
and go back on stage and they're like no
we're sending people home i go okay well
what about the 9 45 show and they're
like no
like emts are coming and he goes that
just shows you like what a professional
you are yeah i guess i mean i've never
you know like when adele was canceling
her shows because in my opinion she's
dick whipped and in love with that guy
yeah there was something going on away
from him 100
yes i'm like i've never canceled a show
in my life what does that say about my
husband's dick
[Laughter]
okay but also the craziest part of the
whole situation was the last words to
leave your lips before you fainted where
jesus loves me the most like you
actually cannot write
ironic
well i have a sweatshirt that says that
and one thing that i've said is
much like you who's like a strong jew i
very much identify as a catholic girl
and a lot of my juicy scoopers
understand
catholic guilt and when you go to
catholic school you have to do this
thing called christian service like you
always have to get your christian
service hours in or whatever so i would
always say that and in like a joking way
but of course i believe in god and jesus
and him but but
i so i'd be like jesus loves me the most
like uh i have never gotten covered like
clearly he loves me the most and anyone
that follows me and knows where i'm
coming from
you know it's fine but other people that
are really like
right-wing
christian that that that's their first
introduction is this obnoxious female
stand-up who's
talking about vaccinations and then
passes out they went off on me
especially on youtube especially all
these like right wing like
men
like crotchety old like white men are
like this is why females aren't funny
and everything i'm like i agree that
wasn't that funny of a joke i was two
minutes into my act like you know you
give me a second like the least funny
stuff up top and then you know
so i'm like great yeah oh my god so i'm
so glad you're feeling better like that
was just so crazy
and you just handled the whole thing
from start to finish like a pro and you
know and actually in one of our facebook
groups someone was there and they were
kind of retelling their experience and
they
for a few minutes people didn't know if
you were joking or not
i know it was it was honestly the best
comedic timing i've ever had in my life
and my first thought was i can't believe
this is real like i was pinching myself
i'm and my son who's uh 19 and a
freshman at asu that was like the first
time he's ever come to the club and seen
me
so we decided it was his fault that he
stressed me out so he did not come this
past saturday he went on like some went
to some
lake with his friends and girls in
bikinis i'm like no you're doing that
you're not seeing your mother pass out
again i'm like i think you stressed me
out because i talked a lot a lot of [ __ ]
about my son and i was like i know you
could handle it but i'm a little bit
nervous right i don't know what it we
still don't know what caused it but it
just happened and and being on stage
with no no one to grab no chair right is
why i felt so fell so
hard right and um
yeah but it was hilarious and so then my
son who's just like my husband he came
down and the hot emts are like we have
the ambulance for you i go okay and my
son's like whoa whoa whoa we're not
paying for an ambulance
we can drive you mom you're fine
no honestly like i'm so glad he was
thinking that way ambulances are
extremely expensive
um no you'll never get it's one of those
things i don't i think you know how like
my um at my daughter's high school um
they i just saw i think it's my same
high school they're now doing this like
like life lesson class
and and i'm like that is so important
like and it's like hygiene
healthcare like all these little things
that you don't learn not just how to
teach a kid and do their laundry in the
dorm right but i'm like that one has to
also be one the ambulance never call an
ambulance i mean unless you're like
really dumb unless you're on death's
door yes because you're calling that
money back even with the best insurance
people don't know that and in new york
it can run you up like 30 grand just to
call an ambulance
wow that's crazy so
so good so blessed that you're doing
well well enough to be here i'm so
excited to have you i have so much i
want to talk to you about in the pop
culture world but before we dive into
the fast five i want to get your take
your season's season comic
you've been at this forever and i know
it's like old news now but i haven't
stopped thinking about the slap and i
would love to hear your thoughts on this
lap
well i was actually performing i was
doing a live juicy scoop and i ran
backstage to like do a quick change and
i had a couple comedians coming out
throughout the show and annie who works
with me goes and she's like helping me
change she goes chris rock just got
slapped by will smith at the oscars and
i immediately thought that's a bit
that's enough because no one cares about
the oscars and then of course when i saw
it um i was obsessed with it i did a lot
of shows on it i went deep dive um
there's just so many layers of it but of
course walking up and and hitting a
comic at all was the most
for i'll say this
i think it's good for comedy actually
because i think the overwhelming support
was this isn't okay this pendulum has
swung too far
we want to preserve the right to uh free
speech but also the profession of
stand-up comedians that they say
shocking things they say things that
aren't true they're not experts
if you're gonna be easily offended don't
buy tickets to a comedy club i think
that
message really helped get across to like
a very
you know post-woke apocalypse world that
we live in and kind of people go yeah
you're right i don't want i don't want
people to be silenced so i think in the
end um it was good for chris rock
selling tickets and
people respect him even more than they
respected him before i mean he would
have done great anyway but yes that
boosted it and for will smith i think um
in the end when he finally is separated
forever from jada he will be a better
human too yes and what do you think the
platform is going to be or it should be
where chris rock finally speaks up
because he's been doing a bunch of shows
and he said at the beginning of the show
like you guys might have all come here
to hear me you know respond but i wrote
this material and it's funny and i want
to do this show so i'm not going to
respond yet but i will so what do you
think it's going to be a special
i think maybe at the end of this he'll
film a special and it'll include that i
think he's just taking time to kind of
figure it out also be sensitive to the
fact that will smith is obviously [ __ ]
up right and uh for a number of reasons
and you know jada's out there on the red
carpet she's making interviews saying i
didn't need defending i mean she's there
was one video i don't know if you saw
this now everyone's pulling stuff from
the red from history right and and where
he said i planned this party for you on
your 37th birthday for the next three
years i planned a 40th birthday for jada
and it was the most fabulous party did
you see this clip i didn't no
okay so he's sitting at the red table
top with willow
willow the grandma and her and he goes
and it was the most fabulous party i
spent three years planning it and
what did you say jada at the at the
party you didn't like it and she goes no
i said that party was for you
it was for your ego that was to feed
your ego and willow goes woof and the
grandma goes
and
will's like and you were right
and i'm like
literally no one's ever thrown me a
surprise party in my life let alone any
kind of party at all i get costco roses
every like every treasure mother's day
every day you know every
mother's day whatever lots of them are
combos you know because mother's day and
my birthday and my anniversary are close
together right i was just like and
and that's what showed me what i've
always thought is
she is jealous of will's career hmm
i think she saw herself as the same
level like when they got together and he
just skyrocketed in these blockbuster
money-making
movies and she's had a very good career
and one that anyone would envy right but
she named like a movie that you know a
movie that she was truly the lead of or
that's like iconic or even if it wasn't
like oscar-worthy like a really fun i
mean she wasn't a pretty woman you know
what i mean it was like
so i just when i saw that i'm like of
course in her mind she's gonna think
oh you did this party so that everybody
would come and say wow
will is the greatest husband ever not
jada's the greatest woman turning 40.
yeah i think like now
knowing what we know about them and then
all these clips resurfacing like they're
the definition of toxic yes
they are not happy and so i think we're
all just kind of rolling our eyes
because they over share quite a bit on
social on red table talk and it's i'm
all for sharing your lives on social
media like i'm the biggest exploiter of
my personal life and even i have things
that are off limits but they don't and
now we're just like enough we've had
enough well you know about like i don't
know 15 i think when i was writing white
chicks actually which i wrote with them
brothers i'm sorry what when i was
writing white chicks with the wayne's
brothers
do you not know this no that's like the
most iconic movie of all time
yes
i worked they they had created the idea
of the movie
and then i went to keenan's house every
day and and wrote the movie with them
heather
yes i was the white girl consultant yes
you literally are oh my god i love that
for you like it makes so much sense
congrats i know that that's that's a
little late and then i had a pardon and
i was the sales girl
like i wrote that scene based on this
girl who worked at this shop on third
street in beverly hills but
um
when that was going on they were friends
you know they're always friends uh
keenan and his wife they're no longer
together but they have five kids one of
their kids was uh jayden's age so they
were very close to will and jada at that
time and um this is when they were would
match on the red carpet
now they had a couple kids they could
not be cuter they were what they were
the definition of couple goals that we
talked about now
and i've said this on like this couple
goals thing
don't ever say a couple goals for me i
think it's a lot of pressure for the
country
and i think
there was and i remember um when tom
cruise and um nicole kidman broke up
i said like with all these guys writing
i go well if jada and will break up the
world's going to lose their mind and he
goes oh my god no we won't be able to
you know with we won't be able to hold
it it's like barack and you know
michelle michelle right can't handle it
and so i think a lot of it is they
probably in my opinion they probably had
they not been on this pedestal yeah i
think they probably would have broken up
maybe like eight years ago you know no
that's a good good call when once their
kids were like teenagers or kinda and
they just were not feeling each other
and they were on different paths and
they've been fighting i mean she said i
cried for 40 days one time and someone
who cries for 40 days if you're not
getting you've got to make it you should
be going through divorce you got to make
a change yeah yeah
okay i'm so i i'm very much on the same
page as you with that whole situation i
haven't stopped thinking about it i
think it's the craziest thing of all
time and i'm very much looking forward
to hearing what chris rock has to say
because we've heard from a lot of people
but we haven't heard from him right oh i
have a question for you speaking of just
this is have you seen that people
believe that kanye who said i'm going
away to get some help is really with the
cheney girl at that beautiful resort in
utah on hungary yes i did not hear that
oh
i i don't know i follow some weird
accounts and i don't know if someone's
creating this story
or if it's really it's it's really her
posting stories
where she's like oh it's my vacation and
she's really feeding into it yeah i
don't know but i mean that's not that's
a beautiful resort but that's not
therapy going with a girlfriend is not
getting mental health no no no it's not
but i'm glad that he has finally quieted
down and is seeking some sort of help um
okay so i think it's time we should dive
into the fast fouries fast five stories
they're really good today and they're
covering a wide range of topics so
without further ado let's dive into the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
relief band nothing in the world is more
annoying than being nauseous i get it
for migraines i get it from hangovers
when jackie was pregnant she had a lot
of morning sickness and one out of three
americans regularly suffer from nausea
and you've got to check out relief band
if you do it is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband that has
been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting that's associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much poor more how it works is
relief band will stimulate a nerve in
the wrist that travels to the part of
the brain that controls nausea then it
blocks the signal your brain is sending
to your stomach that is telling you you
are sick it's just like the name says it
legitimately relieves
nausea and you change the intestine
intensity depending on how you are
feeling to make it either stronger or
weaker for me when i wake up with a
hangover or or i have a really bad
migraine i'll get extremely nauseous and
popping on a relief band will
immediately and effectively relieve
nausea and there's just nothing better
than that it also doesn't make you
drowsy which is a huge bonus it's 100
drug free non-drowsy provides
all-natural long-lasting relief with
zero side effects for as long as you
need and they just released their newest
model which is the relief band sport
that is waterproof it has an extended
battery life and you can attach it to
your apple or android watch don't let
the fear of nausea prevent you from
being present in life's important
moments right now you can join the over
a hundred thousand relief band users
with an exclusive offer just for morning
toast listeners if you go to
reliefband.com and use the promo code
toast you'll receive 20 off plus free
shipping and a no questions asked 30 day
money back guarantee remember it's
better to have relief band and not need
it than to need it and not have it so
head to relief band
b r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a n d dot com use the
promo code toast for twenty percent off
plus free shipping you will not regret
it
today's episode is also brought to you
by roderm so personally i love the look
of false lashes but i don't really like
how tricky they can be to apply how
messy the glue can be it's just not a
premium experience and they're just too
much of a hassle
and you guys know i accidentally singed
off some of my eyelashes in a fire pit
in utah once and they just have never
been the same and that's why i'm really
excited about today's sponsor rohderm
they offer access to clinically proven
eyelash growth serum for people who want
longer thicker darker lashes if the
treatment is right for you you can get
it prescribed online and delivered it's
super easy the results speak volumes in
a 16 week clinical trial eyelashes were
grown by 25 in length 106 in fullness
and 18 in darkness to get your
prescription eyelash growth serum all
you have to do is complete a free online
visit and answer standard questions
about your eye health and medical
history after you submit a road term
affiliated healthcare provider we'll get
back to you within 48 hours if you're
prescribed your serum will be delivered
to your door with free two-day shipping
so there's no need for in-person
appointments which are just the worst
and right now if you're subscribed new
members will receive 10 off the eyelash
growth serum from rowderm when you go to
roadderm.com forward slash toast that's
r o d e r m dot com slash toast shipping
is free you'll get free and unlimited
follow-ups with your healthcare provider
to support you throughout your journey
of eyelash growth rowderm.com forward
slash toast okay first up is the jlo and
ben affleck of it all obviously we know
that they're engaged but now we're
getting some more information because
jlo decided to announce it in like a
really weird thirsty kind of like
patreon-esque way
and
i heard what you said about this
yesterday i said the same thing on my
show tuesday
when i saw that it was like to collect
emails
remember when like stand-ups were doing
this thing like whitney cummings was
doing and all these people even brooke
christopher hey text me they're still
doing it people are still doing it so
what is that they just get a lump sum of
money or what is it no it's just a way
of collecting data on all your fans so
that when you have like merch coming out
or a show coming up you have like a
direct access because email marketing is
like a little old school people are very
much like mobile friendly now so the
texting thing is like oh great now i
have the phone numbers of 10 000 of my
fans and i have to sell out a show let
me send out a text message to those
phone numbers that live in arizona you
know
i feel like that went away though like
there was a little moment where
everybody was doing it and then they
would write back these texts like ha ha
and hey girl and i'm like what the hell
is this no and sometimes if you go on
like a creator's instagram in their bio
it'll be like 917 blah blah text me
right so i don't know but jayla was very
much on that train when she announced
her engagement and it was so murky and
like borderline mysterious that we
didn't even get any information like it
was so weird but then yesterday i did
subscribe to her newsletter so i was one
of the first people to get the
information um we got some new some new
details about the whole thing yeah she's
letting fans know um in her newsletter
that she is talking about her second
chance at true love she said did you
ever imagine your biggest stream could
come true
saturday night while at my favorite
place on earth in the bubble bath my
beautiful love got on one knee and
proposed i was taken totally off guard
and just looked in his eyes smiling and
crying at the same time trying hard to
get my head around the fact that after
20 years this was happening all over
again i was quite literally speechless
and he said is that a yes
i said yes of course that's a yes feels
like teresa giudice wrote this i don't
know why i'm just seeing her and louie
like doing this in the bath
and then i put on my jlo glow serum
and i was so glowy i didn't need any
makeup right next to my jolly rancher
apple uh flavored green ring while
listening to my new song yes yes of
course it was very weird and very not
a-list and j-lo is a-list
well
i mean i was thinking about all the
engagements
the only one she wasn't engaged to was
casper
remember casper and i think that truly
was for the best oh definitely
definitely because remember he was
always like seen coming in and out of
like old-fashioned like
porn shops and stuff and he just was not
of the caliber that a jlo type needs no
definitely not but she had the a-rod was
a you know a beautifully shot
situation on a beach
and i don't remember how mark anthony
went down but like
and of course we remember the pink
diamond the first time with j.lo you
know when they were that was during the
time where she was slicking back his
hair
and they were buying a bentley every
other day and going
and uh
so i think the fact that they did it
that way like privately even though then
she you know talked wrote about it after
and it wasn't a big splash it wasn't in
front of an arena or an award show
i think it's kind of cool you know i
agree for sure they're adults they have
kids and
um
i love a second time around thing
because especially with her like
if you see your old boyfriend from 20
years ago to be able to go oh and by the
way my body is better than it was 20
years ago who has that
opportunity except for jlo no it's not
fair she's more stunning more successful
more famous more everything of the sort
probably better in the sack
100 yeah it's not fair it's not fair
i've always been really hot for ben
affleck he's completely my type
yes but you know the way he like
sprinted away from jlo straight into
jennifer gardner like was definitely
hurtful for j lo but i really was loving
that moment for him like being a family
man their daughter's name is serafina
after my favorite restaurant like i love
that and then he went through this like
really messy couple of years with the
snl writer and yeah and the
jack-in-the-box yeah right right and so
for a while i was like this is america's
sweetheart now he's definitely working
back towards where he once was and i
think jlo has definitely helped
yeah and i mean it's a challenge to
to marry someone that's in recovery but
i mean she's a great match in that she
literally has one glass of champagne a
year if that yeah and so like she
doesn't need it or miss it however i do
remember seeing one photo of them
um
like on a balcony in the beginning of
them dating again and i mean he i think
he still smokes
cigarettes yes
i don't know
i can't deserve wanting to put up with
that i know the breath and the talks and
like the toxins going into your pores
right she's so natural right right right
how many subscribers do you think she
got for her newsletter i think she
probably got
8.92
192 000 is my guess do you know no no no
i was gonna say about a hundred thousand
because like oh really maybe now you're
right maybe that much because even
though i was curious
i was like well there's already articles
written that they got engaged so why do
i need to go and see the thing and get
all the emails sent to me every time
there's like a sale because like she has
20 million followers obviously 20
million people are not setting up for
her dumb ass on the jlo
and you know all the news reporting
really spoiled it like you didn't need
yeah the newsletter because when i got
the people notification i ran to her
instagram and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
on the jlo.com
and do you think though at this time i
mean obviously she couldn't it's if
she's telling the truth she
didn't know when he was going to ask her
and it really was a surprise
i want to say to him though um
god ben could you have waited about a
week and a half until after the
kardashians launched i know
i mean we really could have had a bigger
splash
i know you know can i ask you a question
yes do you struggle because you know you
podcast quite a lot so do we and we get
you know some backlash like all we do is
talk about the kardashians especially in
the last month because every day they've
been giving us just something really
juicy um
do you have a hard time sometimes
finding things to talk about that aren't
the kardashians
um not not really but like i do kind of
want to like go through it quicker like
go through like each person and i mean
i'm not going to report on the you know
true's balloon display you know what i
mean like there's some things that are
like
interesting because they're a jumping
off point of like talking about a bigger
situation with a relationship or
whatever
but i mean god they really
they have really worked hard to get
people to uh newly subscribed to hulu if
they weren't subscribing already i mean
totally
i would have to say you know like
company company girl that kris jenner
you know really really it was like you
will not regret this hulu yeah um i
thought it was kind of funny how like e
news is at the premiere
it's like your ex-boyfriend at your
house that's what i wrote like
i wrote i wrote like it's your
ex-boyfriend coming to the wedding and
it's yes you want to be supportive but
come on it's weird yeah but i guess
there's just nothing they can do because
they say if they're a pop culture thing
what are they not gonna 90 of their
stories are kardashians too so they've
just got to lick their wounds and move
on yeah you know you have been in the
podcasting game long before everyone
else showed up
and i have actually two questions for
you the first is like what are your
thoughts on like everyone you know
getting a platform then be like i think
i'll start a podcast
um for that you know
now i just accept that everyone on earth
will have a podcast it'll be like an
instagram and i'm like hey you know the
technology is there you may not make
money at it but if it's a way to journal
or diary like oh my god i would have
loved to have gone back when i was you
know 22 and heard me do an episode about
my crazy night the night before at usc
like i would freaking love to have that
kind of like
you know
or whatever yeah but um
i really think there are
uh
i remember okay when friends first came
out and friends was popular i was like
out auditioning for things and there
were so many copycat friends shows yeah
there's friends in it there was one
friends in alaska there were friends in
in san francisco and they would just
kind of change up the combination maybe
it wasn't six maybe it was five people
maybe it was three girls and two guys or
three guys and two girls it was and none
of them made it none of the shows made
it for except for friends so
i think that um there are there is room
for like micro
influencers just like there's micro
podcasters there's ways to get ads and
make money and um but as far as like all
these people that you and i used to
interview now all having their own
podcasts i just go hey good luck because
when you're a writer or comedian or
something you can see what the top shows
are because we are able to
without a guest or without a big juicy
interview
do it and the thing is with everybody
having their own podcast there is no
interview to get
they've already spilled it on their own
show they've already gone on 25
different shows yeah so it's still fun
to have those people yeah but you know
once even with me once i i'm like okay i
got that new housewives life story then
the next season comes around and i'm
like sometimes i hit it off with some
people i'm like come on we'll also talk
about your opinion of other things but
other most lots of times i'm like i
already got the life story i was the
first one to get it yeah i don't really
care you know like
so that's kind of what i think about it
and then i guess the second half of that
question is like you
i think maybe i'm wrong but like your
podcast is bigger than it's ever been
like you are really like
chart-topping staying relevant you have
a really really strong audience and
might add they are just lovely lovely
people like just nice girls i really
like them yeah um and what and i guess
this is a question for me like what
advice or how do you maintain that
relevancy i assume it's just like you're
extremely consistent
i definitely think um the consistency is
so important because it's just like when
you have anything your favorite thing in
life like you know if all of a sudden it
goes away or i understand sometimes
people have to take a break and they
should i just treated it
like um kind of like when i produced
chelsea lately and we had like no weeks
off we would do like evergreen shows and
plop them in and and other shows like a
jimmy kimmel they would go off for three
months and things like that and so for
me
it's kind of hard because i'm like oh my
god like i'm never gonna allow myself to
you know really take a real break
because even when you do these shows and
you're on vacation and you still gotta
post that the show was up and all that
kind of stuff but um
i just think um i've just never run out
of something to say you know and um and
i think yeah
you've got to think about that too when
you start a show like is is there enough
to go for years you know
even sometimes with some of these crime
podcasts i'm like
god i mean i i've run out of stories
that i haven't heard yet like what do
you
and you know and there's only so many
that are really juicy yeah you know like
just going to like your local police
department oh this guy was
shot on the corner you're like that's
terrible but this wasn't like a big
conspiracy he wasn't sleeping with the
shooter's wife
you know so i kind of like i don't know
i know i think about that a lot part of
it yeah yeah
today's episode is also brought to you
by olive in june if you are unable to do
your own nails at home
like i was this is the brand for you
olive and june makes it so easy and so
affordable to do your nails at home with
their mani system it breaks down to just
two dollars a manicure which is just an
unbeatable price especially in today's
economy it's so easy to get salon worthy
nails at home with olive and june their
mani system gives you everything you
need to just get the perfect at home
manicure you get up to six polishes and
they've gorgeous polishes that last over
seven days there's no chipping which is
a huge problem for me they also have
press-ons and i'm a press-on nail girly
they look so real they last so long they
have so many different sizes perfect for
whatever size your nail bed is they're
non-damaging and you can get a perfect
manicure in less than 10 minutes so if
you have been struggling with at home
manicures head over to oliveinjune.com
tmt for 20 off your first mani system
that's o l i v e a n d j u n e dot com
slash tmt for 20 off your first manny
system um okay so another news story
that's kind of sad but then have like a
weird twist so obviously yesterday was
reported that gilbert godfried passed
away which is so sad but then his
twitter was hacked um briefly after it
was announced that he died and it was
really like creepy and super [ __ ] up
so on tuesday afternoon the late stars
bio was changed to
hacked by at
ye at archive on instagram an account
that no longer exists on instagram and
then followed by several bizarre tweets
that were deleted but snagged by the
daily mail obviously because the daily
mail is always there for us um and i
just think this is like the most [ __ ]
up thing on the planet
it really is i mean it's
he was you know a really funny guy
he was
i think he was 67 i wasn't aware he was
sick right but so um at least it wasn't
like a sudden thing for his family but
yeah people are gross people just want
that little bit of fame even if it's
anonymous right and at what cost like
literally a man just died yeah it's it's
it's amazing what how gross the world is
especially when it comes to stuff like
that
never ceases to amaze me here are some
of the tweets
um they retweeted someone who wrote
retweet if you eat and then it's blurred
out but i think we can all imagine what
that is
i'm running a deal on my only fans right
now would mean the world if you
subscribed
drain gang blade [ __ ] that they say they
can gang
just like out of control content and not
appropriate
oh
terrible
you know what i also hate is you know
when you have you has this happened to
you where you post something and the
first five comments are like
i can't believe i could make so much
money with josie smith's uh financial
services
and it's like the first i'm always a god
damn it and
that like but i don't know you know
people are desperate and if this is what
they do but this this is really gross
because this is a loved one and this is
right and now you know this becomes a
story instead of like
remembering a great man nice like funny
like guy with a very unique uh
persona and point of view and comedy so
i agree like the lengths that this is
just like for me like really telling of
the links that people will go to
to be relevant on social media whether
it's positive or negative and yes there
are all these weird like scam bot things
especially on instagram that are like oh
my brother said i'm ugly tap my profile
to tell me if i am like stop wait is
this one that i always get that's like
you won't you want to go to the bathroom
after you see my videos
can you believe my latest video
why do guys go into the bedroom after
watching my videos that's like my first
comment after every post mine i'll
always like scroll through and then i'll
see one that's like if i comment this
it'll get buried so it doesn't matter
i'm gay
but i don't think it's like a genuine
coming out story i think it's like
clickbait it is so weird instagram like
really needs to do something about that
yes i've been commenting more now
um
where i'm just like
well sometimes i that's when i got in
trouble with the not in trouble but i
when i said something to chrissy teigen
but like now i used to not comment under
other things but now i'm just like like
i saw that like garcelle's book is
coming out you know and she had all
these she did a compilation video of all
these
celebrity friends going it's here it's
here it's here so then i just wrote
under and i said even though you didn't
contact me to vid film myself saying
it's here i'm still happy about your
book
because i'm like i've worked with you
i've interviewed you why didn't you tell
me ask me for a video
yeah
and did you see that erica and her
obviously having some sort of
something because erica threw away her
book and posted it on instagram
i love it because what erica doesn't
realize is that really helps sell her
book even more i know i was actually
thinking like if you really hate
garcelle then don't post that because
people were like oh i didn't know
garcelle wrote a book can't wait to go
check it out yeah yeah i know like what
she was like
and also i was disturbed and i'm not
like a freak
like i i mean i am good i'm really good
about um you know recycling but like
that whatever trash can that was i hope
that it wasn't hers because it was
she had an old telephone in there yeah
it wasn't do that it was a unique
mixture of items that big old telephone
like recycle it give it away and then
she had like a plastic bottle and a red
bull like that's not supposed to go on
the same thing as right and she lives in
west hollywood where i feel like they're
extremely strict about recycling
i mean everybody is they they make it so
easy for you what's wrong not enough
well baby i never had to do it when i
was with tom girardi it's true it's true
she never had to recycle her own trash
did you see her tweets last night oh no
what did she do oh my god she was going
crazy about
just she's just like i'm the lord who
wants to write me and then it was like
you know a lot of like you know dick
emojis and and wet things where people
said who are you dating or something and
she's like like i'm getting you know i'm
getting she's getting this but i'm still
married and it was really nasty stuff
but i have to say she's pretty clever
like pretty quick with the sexual
comebacks on the on the twitter like yes
she is yeah i'm like i don't think she
was that bright but and by the way where
do you stand now with the erica jane of
it all like do you think she know
i
i think she
i mean i think she's got to take some
responsibility for it but i also think
that um
i didn't i don't think she like looked
into it i mean there's so many women
that and especially in her situation and
then i think he was like spend whatever
you want
and she didn't ask she didn't want to
know
and i yeah and then also once she knew
he was cheating i mean there's nothing
worse than being 23 years younger than
your husband or 27 years younger than
your husband hot as [ __ ] getting plastic
surgery every year and he's this old
bald waddling man and he still wants to
sleep with someone other than you right
like he's the one cheating on you that's
not how it's supposed to work and i
always think the fact that he cheated
with a judge it's like you know is no
matter how many new boob jobs and eye
lifts you get you can't go to a plastic
surgeon and get a better brain
so like he was cheating with a girl who
was really smart
yeah and i just think that really pissed
her off and her revenge was
not revenge but just i'm going to spend
even i'm going to be spending even more
because i remember i had privy to like
or maybe it's out there
how in the beginning of their marriage
what her like american express bill was
and it literally went from shopping at
like bb
to then like bcbg
to then like sax to then like going
straight to the louis vuitton store
right right and it was so it was just
like you know she she's like that 30
year old girl that gets a rich boyfriend
she's like i can buy these little brown
baby kitten heels you know like
like oh my god you're gonna buy me a
bottle of shampoo and then realizes no i
can spend a lot more than this i can get
rid of cartier
and even like someone who
works for their money would be like i'm
not gonna buy my diamonds at tiffany's
i'm going to
go to a really great jeweler right and
like get you know and
same quality yeah because it's same
quality but even for better i'm not
going to do this labelly thing but for
her it was like i want to flash to the
world that i'm so rich and then when she
realized that he you know that they
weren't even and i i heard that like
there were times where
you know um
she wanted her divorce or he wanted to
vote and she was like it'll cost you so
much more to divorce me
than if you just let me spend whatever i
want becoming this you know fake pop
star right and that being the pop star
cost so much money i mean she did not
make any money no
performing until uh until housewives
right and i think she said she was
spending 40 grand a month on just hair
and makeup that's just glam that's not
getting all the guys hotel rooms
wardrobe flying them so you can do like
gay pride in dallas like
you know and for what you know
for what you you're telling me you're
making money off of those itu downloads
no you know
no music is a tough business so i don't
know i don't know what will happen i
think um
i mean i think she'll she'll continue to
have fans sell her hair extensions be on
the show
and be able to survive that way even if
she has nothing really to show from the
20 years of being with tom girardi in
the end totally and you know what
speaking of divorce that's a great segue
into our third story which is really
juicy
julia hart who obviously we all know
from my unorthodox life allegedly wired
50 000 of company money to hire her
divorce lawyer so page six obviously has
the exclusive that the my unorthodox
lifestyle was fired from her role as ceo
of elite world group in february
amid her nasty divorce with the owner of
elite world group silvio and i like how
they left that out of the show you know
like she was a self-made woman but her
husband ran the company it was very yeah
so now page six has documentation
showing that julia's assistant used
funds from e-1972 which is elite worlds
group made to measure clothing brand she
used money to pay for a retainer for a
divorce attorney at miller zeiterman llp
and it is unclear whether julia hart
reimbursed the company for the fifty
thousand dollars the email that page six
had has her assistant saying please see
the signed retainer attached i will need
an invoice for the fifty thousand
dollars this will be coming from e 1972
inc
so um i don't know if they planned on
reimbursing but if they didn't this
assistant is one of the worst criminal
cover-ups of all time she literally
wrote an email saying exactly the crime
she's committing
well i mean i almost think that makes
julia look better that that was her
assistant
that it was that they were being honest
about it like right i need an attorney
and if i don't have 50 000 in a personal
account
and
and this is a company i i think that one
the made to order was one that she
created with
under the the thing of the umbrella yeah
yes so um i mean i don't think that's
that bad i mean the thing is whether
you're really really rich
or you're uh you know and you have your
own business or you're the housewife
that wants to leave the husband i mean
when women are are with a guy and they
want to leave
um they have to start stipending money
for months and months and months
they you know have to blindside them
they go and and pay for the kid's school
for the year on the georgia account they
you know so that they're not screwed
so i mean it happens even when you're
really wealthy and so i don't think 50
000 is the worst the 850
that he's saying she also took from the
company i don't really
know about that but um
i don't you know i look
it
it's a very interesting story i've hung
out with her a number on a number
occasions no way what she like
tiny interesting because she's she
doesn't know a lot about the world
because she was living in this place
where she didn't watch tv or anything
right right so if i would just mention
something like oh remember when julia
roberts was engaged to um
who was the country guy that everyone
thought was so ugly kenny chesney
no no that was um
that's even too far back but if i just
said anything like
something a reference pop culture from
like 12 years ago
she doesn't she doesn't know and i go
did you ever watch that show
kimmy schmidt or whatever and she i was
just going to say she's a mole woman and
she said i saw a little of it and
honestly it was too disturbing for me
because she's like i really didn't
like get to do all these things and i
my question was always just like i just
okay so you're you're wearing
you know the the conservative clothes
you're making your own matzoh ball soup
you're raising these kids you're living
like a you know still like you're in a
nice house you're not like
and then all of a sudden you create a
company
and then
are traveling as an executive and sell
it to this other company and like
fall in love with this guy and get
married and and one of my questions that
i had for her when i interviewed her i
was like i just
when you go from like you know
being very humble in a lot of ways with
your clothes and stuff how do you just
feel comfortable buying chanel underwear
within like eight years even if you have
the money
and she just was like well it's my money
i made the money too and i was like okay
you know i i'm like i'm literally asking
when someone
how do you change your mind about money
so quickly because no and by the way i
think you're asking something like a lot
of people for me like what i took away
from the show was like i didn't really
feel like they did a good job explaining
how she got from point a to point b
yeah and and that's because the show did
it failed to mention that the man she
was living with and married to owned the
company because it's very difficult to
become the ceo of a fortune 500 company
when you don't have a master's degree or
and just selling your shoe company to a
big conglomerate like i just i didn't
understand the path and how she got from
a to b so i think a question like that
is extremely fair
well when i was talking to her um i did
an interview with her and then we hung
out on like two other occasions
but she just would say it's in the book
it's in the book the book
the book is not she's a sales woman on
netflix got it got it and i believe that
i think if people are really curious i
think if they read
the book they're go there hopefully
we'll get the answers or we'll start to
get reviews that you know um
but she's just she's very sweet she's
very
very petite and
tiny and we went to the gucci fashion
show she invited me to the gucci fashion
show in l.a did you go yes oh fun
very very weird i've never been to
anything like that and
um
like i'm just very fascinated by like uh
models
trying to make themselves ugly today i i
don't get i come from like
you know the cindy crawford times where
you know only the most beautiful people
you know and like and there and some of
these people are beautiful but they'll
have them like
make them ugly yeah make them makeup's
ugly the outfits are ugly i so there was
a lot of that like a lot of terrifying
things but it was a cool experience
oh i'd love that for you what did you
wear
i i just wore like an alice in olivia
what did i wear alice and olivia
dress and cute like jacket that was like
embroidered and stuff
and some you know boots and i i mean i
don't have gucci clothes i didn't bring
you just a bag but i don't of course
yeah i'm not dorit you know no right who
has gucci clothes like that's insane
so it's time to ditch the chemicals with
caraway's non-toxic home cookware and
bakeware collections so you can make
healthier cooking a piece of cake their
non-toxic kitchenware from caraway are
all designed for the modern home and
they feature a chemical-free ceramic
coating so food can be prepared with
peace of mind that no hard-to-pronounce
compound will leech into your healthy
ingredients the colors are also stunning
so i have the cookware set so it's a
modern and chemical free iteration of
the traditional 16 piece set comes with
a fry pan a saute pan a saucepan and a
dutch oven which is really all you need
they also have a bakeware set it's an
assortment of non-toxic baking
essentials that every modern kitchen
needs so you can get to baking goods
without any of the bads they're really
really gorgeous they store really well
they have this great stacking system so
if you visit
dot com toast you can take advantage of
this limited time offer for 10 off your
next purchase the deal is exclusive to
our listeners so visit carawayhome.com
toast or just use the code toast to
check out caraway it's non-toxic
cookware made modern
um okay moving on hayley bieber is like
having such a hard time she's begging
people on social media just to leave her
alone she posted a video on tiktok on
tuesday basically she didn't say
outright but it appears as though she's
addressing like the jelena fans people
who are still holding out hope for
justin bieber and selena or as i like to
call them [ __ ] losers
and she just wrote she's talking to the
camera and she says this is for you guys
in my comments every single time i post
enough time has gone by i'm minding my
business i don't do anything i don't say
anything leave me alone please i beg of
you truly that's my only request be
miserable somewhere else please um
i have spoken like at length about how
like there are people who wake up every
day and choose to
to daydream about justin and selena
getting back together and those people
are such losers and anytimes you know
haley posts on social media the comments
are like selena would never do that
and then she gets paparazzi and the
paparazzi you're like selena what do you
think about selena it's like leave this
[ __ ] alone like she's been married for
almost four years like can she get some
peace
well the fact that you say it's selena
gomez i now have a whole
different perspective i mean that's what
page six thinks it's about and that's
what i assumed it was about you know
because um
i once did
some i just i remember i i was at the
grocery store and i saw something
selena's best friend or something this
girl is her best friend and i'm like
wait didn't she get
francia raisa from her best friend yes
and they don't talk anymore this is not
the girl that was featured in the
magazine as being her best friend
so i
said oh so she's got a new best friend
what about the girl that came and i'm
always like obsessed with like i
remember like george lopez the comedian
his wife gave him a kidney but then they
still wanted a divorce and did she want
it back in the divorce i mean i just
think it's like a such a i am going to
ask someone for and to receive and i
used to joke like god you imagine if you
if you did receive the kidney from
someone and then you're like hey can you
pick me up for the airport they're like
oh my god i can't it's like it's fine i
only gave you your
life literally like i'll i'll get in an
uber don't want to inconvenience you
like it's just going to be like
the forever thing that you owe this
person for yeah i just like made a
little joke about it what did you say i
put it on tiktok and it went insane
and
i literally like
was terrified
i took it down
and then about a week after two weeks
after
every time i posted anything it was all
these selena gomez fans with snakes and
keep selena's name out of your mouth
and then when i really and i was like
first i was looking at i was like god
these selena teenagers don't they have
like an honors paper to write or
something why are they trying to do this
and then i realized no i think they're
all bots i don't know if she's in charge
of it i don't know for pr companies in
charge of it but there is no way these
were all actual individual people
writing me
there aren't that many losers in the
world like they're really a lot and i'd
like block every single one and ever and
now i was lying at him and that's when i
realized that like if you say anything
negative about her or somebody else
in pop culture
it's like i don't know if someone runs
it if she's aware of it but it's an
automatic onslaught to make you shut up
and they did they shut me up
i mean i i won't ever post about selena
gomez i will keep her name out of my
mouth except when i'm talking to you on
morning toast but i will never post
about her again so it's like it's the
same kind of like mafia mentality right
of like i don't want to [ __ ] with that
you know so
see my and i have to say like i was a
selena hater for many years and i've
admitted recently that like i've
recently fallen in love with selena
gomez i think her makeup is incredible i
have it all literally right here i think
she was amazing and only murders in the
building and i've recently become like a
really big fan of hers
but i think i would be remiss not to
mention the fact that she doesn't talk
to the girl who gave her a kidney is
extremely bizarre
well these these selena fans tried to
explain that they're good they're fine
why are you talking about it you old
woman you know so i think that um
so i don't know like why who these
people are whether she's in charge of it
whether she's not in charge of it um i
think she's really talented and
beautiful too i mean it doesn't make any
sense when she and justin bieber have
been married for all these years
so it
yeah i really like i said i really don't
know why people do but i also think
that
i know it's hard because people in the
state they can't give up their social
media and it is disturbing when you see
all these awful comments and they're the
first you know 100
but um
i guess maybe it's okay that she brings
it up
haley berry yeah so people know that
like it is kind of a shitty thing to
wake up to like even though you're
waking up to like justin bieber in a
beautiful house and you know a cute dog
it's like it seems not a great morning
it's still not a good morning for you
you know so
and you know these whether they're bots
are human beings like they idolize
justin and honestly like if i was haley
i would be like [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
ass up and work like go on social media
and tell people to leave me alone like
it's she's out here fending for herself
when really at the end of the day the
only person they actually might listen
to is justin
what she should have done is she sort of
said
you know
it's i was reading these awful comments
with snake emojis and all this stuff and
that's when i had my mini stroke
and then make them all feel really bad
that they caused it yeah we live in such
a [ __ ] up day and age like no one
would care
yeah
that would do nothing
yeah we do nothing
um our fifth and final story is a little
plastic surgery news because you know we
love some good filler and simon cowell
has removed all the face fillers from
his face after he quote went too far so
he did a sit-down interview with the sun
and he basically said there was a stage
where i might have gone a bit too far i
saw a picture of me from before the
other day and i didn't recognize it as
me at all
enough is enough
now there is zero filler in my face and
there was a phase where everyone was
having their faces pumped full of this
and the other but actually for me now a
lot of it comes down to healthy eating
and drinking tons of water the only good
thing of getting older is you have a lot
of experience and it's not always about
the things you did well it's also about
the things you didn't he also goes on to
say like his kid was like freaked out um
when he saw his face because it was like
so full and people have been like
posting pictures for years of simon
cowell like his face looking different
being mean to him um
and i just want to say normalize getting
filler and normalize changing your mind
and getting them taken out
i i mean i love that he's being so
honest we we're a family that watches
america's got talent so we were there
when he was normal and then we were
there when he looked like he put on a
mask
and
i think it's
and i think people people shouldn't be
so harsh on people because even the best
doctors you know and often what happens
especially with like people that are not
huge stars like a
you know a social influencer or a
reality star is they go and then someone
is like
come into my office you want free botox
and then they get free botox and maybe
they just got their lips done like four
months ago and they're like while i'm
here do you want a little bit more
and you really don't have to refill
filler as much as as a botox situation
right that's what happens that's when
people start getting the enormous cheeks
and the lips and they start to look
weird and let me just tell anyone that's
thinking about this because i have had
it happen
when you have the filler removed
it is
so incredibly painful
way more painful than putting it in
so just
just like be very careful with it
and and really think about
like
i mean it's amazing how much people can
change their faces with like a new
jawline and cheekbones and it's so
beyond but just know once you kind of
start that like is that something
you want to keep up it's like the same
time where people are like you know when
i got rid of my highlights it just was
too much i just you know it's like or
nails or whatever like it's a big
expense and then
um but what's good about filler is like
you can get filler and go like two years
and it's gone and nobody notices
providing you do it right no one knows
that it's gone now yeah and so um
i can i just see how it can happen
especially with stars and it's just like
yeah like i was in high school people
were into going to tanning salons
and they'd get their
and then but it was all we'd call it
tanorexia yeah in that they looked in
the mirror and they still saw a pale
person they did not see so they kept
getting tanner and tanner and i think
that happens a lot with plastic surgery
yeah and i think also with plastic
surgery like people change their mind
trends change things go in and out of
style so like i don't know sometimes i
look back i don't get a ton of plastic
surgery but i get filler in my lips and
i'm just going to say your lips look
really good thank you so much i'm at a
good place now but in order to get to
this place i had to go more i had to go
less and i'll see pictures and i'm like
oh my god i look [ __ ] crazy but i
thought i looked good in the moment and
it is what it is
it's a slippery slope though for sure
i i i definitely think it is and i think
it's also what i like about filler and
stuff is that it is kind of a trend and
oh but what i do want to warn the young
girls about
because um is what do we call it annie
and he works with me the way they take
out the fat in your cheek
buckle fat removal have you heard of
this you got to try it no you don't no
you do not okay from someone who has
i've never had cheek filler or anything
i've always had this kind of like fuller
face yeah and
now that i'm old it's really served me
well but what i've heard is like a bella
hadid allegedly
got this taken down so that she had and
then filled the cheekbones got it you
got and then you know along with the
nose and the lip and a
fox eye and this that it looks
absolutely stunning
but now she looks like she's 40.
yes and you're not going to be able to
get that fat back so it's like i
definitely don't think people should get
if you have a little baby
round face
just love it
yes and you have a nice little baby
round face and you need to you know
because it will it will serve you well
as you continue on you look beautiful
now but you will you'll be that girl
that looks young at 45. do you know what
i did do though like a couple years ago
i had like fat um taken out of my neck
because i had like a big double chin
um and it was the most glorious thing i
ever did it was incredibly painful the
chin thing or the what do you call the
shots that they do kybella i don't know
if that works that well but no i
wouldn't advise again and all that i
think is great that's what i did i did
chin lipo and i went in for kybella and
my plastic surgeon who was featured on
the real housewives of new york um she
basically said she does not recommend
kybella it is incredibly painful and
there's like a 50 success rate so it's
like to go through all that for 50 50
[ __ ] no
and and then when you um
do it you can't go out for like a month
you're looking like you have a um
like a like a
a troll face like a natural a toad a toe
yes yes yes yes yes like a big turkey
neck yeah
i don't recommend kybella um but i did
love my lipo journaling i also got to
get a tenderness i also heard threading
doesn't work
okay so a lot of people are into
threading and i have seen so many videos
of people who had threading gone wrong
threading is basically they put threads
in your face like under your skin and
pull your face back so it's like a
outpatient like uh facelift kind of
they're so dangerous like there's so
many people i've seen who've had it like
done incorrectly yeah so i mean all
those things like yeah just be careful
with it yeah and don't and also i don't
think some people don't start so young
because it's just
i agree you can look and you can be 26
and you can look like a 42 year old mom
with work done like you know there is
like a youthfulness about a 27 year old
face that you want to hang on to i agree
i agree um heather i literally would
take a bullet for you thank you so much
for coming on i really don't want you to
no but like i would um thank you so much
for coming on everyone if you don't i'm
sure you already do check out heather's
podcast juicy scoop how many episodes
you drop every week
um every tuesday and thursday and then a
patreon on friday and more yes we love a
patreon queen so check out juicy scoop
father follow heather on instagram she's
unhinged in the best possible way thank
you so much for being here thank you
guys for listening to the morning toast
and i will see you tomorrow in studio
with joey comasta goodbye
thank you